he's one of the best in the business and
the pittsburgh still uh to use the famed
godfather three phrase every time you
think they're out
they bring themselves back in
and the pittsburgh steelers are
currently sitting there at seven six and
one in the mix
in this crazy mixed up afc in 2021
joining us here is uh from the uh
pittsburgh steelers pro bowler minker
fitzpatrick on the mercedes benz vans
phone line how are you makeup
i'm good i'm good how are y'all doing
i'm doing fine i called in and all i
heard was uh screaming and yelling and
talking about i caught the ball yeah all
this crazy
it was it was uh on on our pregame show
on nfl network nfl game day morning uh
on the demo field which is right in
front of the home of super bowl uh 56
yeah so far stadium
um i i i'm out there catching passes um
which you know not many hosts are asked
to do to be honest with you
i haven't dropped one all your irv
michael irvin's dropped a couple so i i
i'm saying it with my chest these days
uh minka so i said i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna drop a football the rest of the
year and um i'm already one for one in
that department so gotcha there you go
there you go maybe it's because you're
not playing defense on me maybe that's
what it is
did i see you on game day morning
yesterday did when you arrived did you
arrive in uh in uh alabama colors
yesterday minkah did i see that so
so let me tell you i lost i lost the bet
to one of my homeboy
and uh i had to dress
uh i don't know if you've seen you know
steve harvey how he has all these
different suits and crazy you know
outfits yeah i lost the bed and my
homeboy got to pick uh two two uh suits
for me to wear that uh that were
fashioned by steve park so i had to wear
that one uh
yesterday the all red and with black
shoes looking crazy and then uh next
week i to work even crazier so can i ask
you what the wager that uh put you on
the losing side was
so so you know again fifa says soccer
game okay
yeah so we played the best two at three
he beat me first time and that was just
for one that was just for one one two
okay and then i was like
double or nothing sorry i lost again
okay let me gotta
let me ask you this um
look you're a two-time all-pro minko so
clearly you coming to work with cameras
on eyes on you
uh that's a that's a that's a hefty
price for you to put out there what
about your who's your friend what what
what was your friend putting up that
might be somewhat maybe
all he had it was an affair it wasn't a
fair bit all he had to do was wear a
suit that i picked uh to work
one day and that's it other cameras
trained on him coming to work or what no
he
works uh you know regular nine to five
all right it was it was more it was an
unfair bet for sure
lopsided
okay it was just yeah lopsided it was
just more about the competitive
competitiveness okay i like it i like it
who who's your who's your who do you
play in fifo who's your who's your guy
that you play in there i'm a liverpool i
like liverpool uh
yeah yeah okay salah so you're you're a
most solid guy
all right exactly minka fetch patrick
learning more and more these days so
to what do you owe the resilience of
your team
minka
to what do you owe that
i would just say um
i'll just say our will to to find ways
to win
i think um
you know a lot of teams when you know
they're down in my guys that we are you
know when we have the uh
amount of you know things going against
us that we have had
you know you see a lot of teams kind of
fold and um
and not step up to the plate but we've
had a lot of young guys a lot of
inexperienced guys come up and step up
to the plate and we got coach t
uh holding us accountable to the same
standard as as you know the players
before and uh to the just the high
standard that he holds everybody to
including himself so it's a combination
of uh a will to you know keep pushing
keep fighting uh even when we're down
big even when we're you know still in
the game just keep pushing and also uh
you know just our leadership coach t
with coach t let's uh let's talk more
about coach tomlin what does he do what
does he say that that translates that
does resonate
when when uh you need it most
what does he do yeah i think i think um
i think it's just how we move throughout
the week there's nothing that he said in
the moment you know i'm saying it's it's
how we move throughout the week it's
attention to detail is uh communicating
on all fronts it's being transparent you
know being open and honest about what we
need to work on and you know putting it
up in front of the team you know i'm
saying and saying hey look this is
something we need to fix if you don't
get it fixed you're gonna find somebody
else that can fix it you know what i'm
saying and you know that puts the chip
on people's shoulder and makes them and
humbles them you know i'm saying that
he'll do it to anybody he's done it to
me before he's gonna
bend before he's gonna be tj before he
does it to anybody so they're going just
moments like that
um and then just like i said before this
is the standard of excellence that he
holds everybody to he's not letting
anybody slack in practice and not let
nobody you know just
mope about throughout the day it's uh
it's a high energy uh attention to
detail uh all throughout the week
what do you mean he's told you he's told
you minka fitzpatrick if you're not
gonna do the job we'll we'll find
somebody else he's literally told you
that
before
i mean i mean
you know he say to me you know there's a
point in the season where i wasn't
tackling good enough you know what i'm
saying earlier this year and he didn't
say those words exactly to me but you
know he was getting on me about it and
said hey if you don't fix it you're
gonna have to
you know do something to change it up
you know not put you know friends like
that so
um
like i said just being open when i said
he wasn't saying i'm gonna replace you
but he's saying we gotta find something
you know to fix it well uh you and you
make a fatigue here on the rich eisen
show i mean i'm not telling any details
out of school here when i say that chase
claypool your teammate had quite a very
long week i know that sometimes it helps
to have a mini buy and have an extra
time between games but for him i imagine
that was an even longer week did you say
anything to him
anything or how did the team
uh
either talk to him or rally around him
how how would you determine mickey
fitzpatrick no i mean i i think we all
um
the dudes that needed to talk to him
talk to him uh
coach t addressed it as well uh in a
fashion you know that i had just
mentioned
um
and that's it you know saying you learn
from it you move forward
um and he is up to him he wants to you
know change
uh and fix
you know uh
you know his
attention to detail and the way he moves
throughout the game so
um you know we're not we're not a team
that's gonna
be ragging on a guy or beating him up
like something that he did we all made
mistakes but like i said we're also
gonna hold him accountable to make sure
it doesn't happen again do you have any
thoughts on the subject of music for
practice while we're on the subject
matter
do you have any thoughts on that um
i i don't know i've been at teams where
we had no music i've been at teams where
you have music playing the whole
practice
i mean i think the players determine the
energy
um you know because t decides to turn it
off and because we just warm up with the
music anyway
all right so it's not totally music free
once you get out on the field is what
you're saying no i'm not yeah okay we
got a little bit of music in the
beginning we're warming up all right
individuals and then once you start
practice practice
if uh there's no sound was one of those
teams that you were on that had music
practicing alabama crimson tide football
or no
he had no music
we
all right very good and i want to circle
back with saban in a second vinca
fitzpatrick here on the rich eisen show
so what what do you what what do you
think you guys can do this year i mean
you're still alive it's really
remarkable the number of times where we
thought you were down and out and and
and this afc just keeps on changing each
week and you with it it appears
how far do you think you can go
vinca with your opportunity
i'm a guy that takes it one week at a
time um you know we got a big team in
kansas city uh
going out there playing them um
not being their top of the
conference or
their division for sure right now so
um we got to go out there
play at a high level compete
and win the game you know saying that's
that's all that we can focus on we're
taking it one week at a time a couple
minutes left here with mikka fitzpatrick
of the pittsburgh steelers i don't know
if you did get a chance to watch the
sunday night game saints and bucks did
you get a chance to
there was a moment in the game where
chris godwin gets knocked out because
the saints defender hit him low and he
caught him in the leg just as his leg
was still on the ground and and his knee
you know buckled and out for the game
could be out for the rest of the regular
season chris collinsworth who called the
game on nbc former receiver was saying
how that's a defenseless receiver and
perhaps hits like that should be
uh considered illegal
you're laughing already i'll give you
the floor man they all know what they
expect this is doing to anyone man it's
this
obviously you don't want to get nobody
hurt you know i'm saying we'll be
praying for for god when he's a great
player
for speedy recovery but
at that at the same time it's
i had to play last
against the vikings the last game while
i hit the guy clean hit shoulder to
shoulder hit him hard and the rest is
like he was right there you know i'm
saying threw the flag on me right and
it's like
what what are we doing man like and it
was clear that replay everybody the
whole stadium was going you know i'm
saying we were at the vikings right uh
stadium old stadium was born and it's
like
you're a part of football
is is is that it it's a violent sport
you know i'm saying people are gonna get
hit hard legally people are gonna get
hurt you know you don't want you don't
will that you don't want that but it's
part of the game you know what i'm
saying and
if you can't play defense just like
if i have to think about how i'm hitting
this person or rather than just going
for the ball you know say obviously i'm
not trying to take your head off but i'm
gonna let you feel me i want you to feel
me i'm not gonna let you
catch the ball and and
you know
make you feel comfortable catching i'm
gonna make i want to make you
uncomfortable as part of the game you
know what i'm saying so i think people
need to
uh
i understand you don't want to protect
people you want to make the game safer
but at the same time you have to
understand the type of game that we're
playing and all the players know we're
signed up for all the players know that
it's 100 guaranteed people get hurt you
know i'm saying um but
there's just some things that
it's it's this this is hard man they're
making the game real hard on defenders
uh
but it isn't i i hope that that never
happened you know i know that and you
know collinsworth obviously played in a
couple super bowls he knows the position
as well maybe you know and
here's the thing is it true though that
in that sequence in minnesota that you
were telling the official that you did
not
make contact with the receiver's head
and you both
watched the replay on the monitor on the
big screen as it showed you did not
touch him in the head as the ref was
telling you you did is that true yeah
yeah uh so they had the big screen right
we were in the end zone we go up like
like a two-yard line and i'm looking up
clear as they see he was looking at me i
don't think he's looking at the monitor
and i'm like i'm pulling at the screen
i'm like i didn't hit him in the head
and he go he like looks at me he's like
yeah you hit him right
careful
careful
just don't stare that's all i'm saying
don't stare at the other don't stare oh
my gosh
no eye contact i know uh before i let
you go i i've asked this question of uh
quarterbacks mostly at alabama two has
answered it mac jones has answered it
now uh bryce young the heisman trophy
winning quarterback has answered it i'll
ask you what's the most upset you ever
made nick saban
minka fitzpatrick oh
man
i got a lot of
momentum okay i said i said one that
made him upset but it was also kind of
funny
um
so
my junior year yeah we're playing texas
a m
and uh
we were we were up i think it's like a
couple points and they were kicking off
sidekick and i was the uh you know the
guy that would catch the ball on the
left side yeah for the onside kick and
everybody i'll catch the ball
so they kicked it right at me and i
caught it as soon as i caught it i
looked to my right and i seen nothing
but green you know what i'm saying you
you always was just picking me no matter
what the circumstance is uh in that
situation
so i so i i caught the ball and i looked
to my right see nothing was green so i
just take off running boom full speed
and i get to like the 10 yard line and i
wasn't going to score but i seen the
kicker coming so i just like kind of ran
out of bounds
and uh i get to the sound everybody's
like excited oh you know a great player
when i get i get to the sideline coach
saban is just ripping me he's like
spitting all of my visor and getting
into my face and he's like
he was he was ripping me a new one but i
think it was funny because like you know
nothing bad happened but you know he
wasn't pleased with it at all do you
ever go to him later on when it's all
cool and you know everybody's cool down
from er from the heat of the moment and
just review like hey you know i mean i
i still didn't score i mean we still got
the ball better field position
no
because you know tua tua did that with
him when he
the thing that he said that he made nick
the most upset was when he took that
sack before you know throwing the
game-winning throw to win the national
champs against georgia he said saban was
so upset with him and he kind of went up
to him after the game like you know i
did make the throw to win it he said it
kind of made it worse kind of made it
worse
yeah that would definitely make it worse
you sometimes just got to know when to
take the l and just keep moving on i
guess exactly well you didn't yesterday
that's for sure thanks for the call
minka fitzpatrick let's do this more
often and i will be certain to have my
eyes peeled on your arrival next week to
see what else you you have to wear to
wrap things up for your uh wager loss
thanks for the call mika you be well all
right appreciation you got that it's
right back at you minka fitzpatrick
everybody of the victorious pittsburgh
steelers
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here